meaningful to people I don't think I
fully understood the scope of it until I
started talking about this character
and I've just been reading every Marvel
comic that's ever been created Berean
understood that wish fulfillment of
becoming a superhero
and now after Marvel is about to take
the leave and be at the forefront of the
entire Marvel Cinematic Universe
that we can have a symbol that
represents strength and humility and
compassion
feels really valuable it's incredibly
difficult
loving and supportive that everyday has
felt fun I think that's what makes for
the magic that you see on screen
I feel like my whole life has sort of
accumulated to this moment
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody is Charlie's surprise
surprise we got a new Captain Marvel
promo to break down there's even more
footage coming next week - so no worries
there's also some cool stuff that
dropped separate from this that I'll add
to the video to this sort of clarifies
what's going on with all the characters
and what the scrolls mission on planet
earth actually is we'll do a new round
of that IMAX ticket giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite Captain Marvel
moment on the video so first big thing
brie larson talking about the character
with Kevin Feige and the directors in
the background of some of these shots -
you see her sitting in her Captain
Marvel gear unzipped like she's wearing
just like a regular jacket this is the
actual costumes like when she's not
shooting scenes they do try to make it
comfortable for the actors especially if
they have to wear those for like a 12
hour shoot people like Karen Gillan
probably have it the works though
because they have like a giant headpiece
that they have to have on at all times
you see more footage of Nick Fury and
shield rolling up to that blockbuster
the next morning after she crashed lands
into the action movie section then you
see her trying to use that payphone just
a little while later I do appreciate
brie Larson talking about reading every
possible Marvel comics she could get her
hands on they announced her a couple
years ago so this picture of her
actually reading that Captain Marvel
comic was right after I think they
publicly announced her there's more new
footage of her looking through her files
at the shield facility that Nick Fury
takes her to looking at a picture of
herself as an Air Force pilot remember
big theme of the movie is that her past
as essentially fever dreams that she has
every once in a while so she's not sure
if there are real memories or if they're
fakes as he tries to find that out over
the course of the movie there's a couple
new scenes of her getting really punchy
like maybe there's a scroll somewhere
hiding out because remember the scrolls
have already infiltrated shield Nick
Fury's boss is Talos the leader of the
scroll Secret Invasion so maybe when
she's walking through the archives he or
she bumps into one and that winds up
being the scroll that we see them
looking at on the table that's also
inside this special facility with
Coulson and Nick Fury in the background
there's more footage during that Los
Angeles train fight when she's fighting
the old lady scroll old lady puncher
Captain Marvel for the win Nick very
chasing after them in his car that might
be before you see them on the highway
here where she's actually start to
explain her backstory noble Creemore
e'er pretty loaded comment from Kevin
Feige - saying she's about to take the
lead in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
for a couple of reasons one -
because she's getting a solo movie that
will premiere in a couple months so
she'll literally be at the forefront of
Marvel's marketing and all the attention
but within the university in a second
big reason why she's coming to the
forefront is because of her comic book
history and her involvement with the
Avengers as a figure of authority her
relative power levels compared to the
other Avengers she is a cosmic level
hero and they're only a couple that can
claim to be that strong on the Avengers
you know like Hulk one of the strongest
Avengers Thor one of the strongest
Avengers vision when he still had the
mind gem for the very same reason you
could call Scarlet Witch a cosmic level
character because of the way her powers
work and how she got them from the
Infinity stones and because they just
continually grow with no end in sight
they're also implying that she's going
to become one of the figures of
authority to replace people like say
Captain America when he rides off into
the sunset
whichever theory you want to endorse how
that goes down before I talk about
Captain America theories remember Joe
Russo said something really interesting
where he's like I don't think that Chris
Evans is done playing Captain America
after Avengers endgame this is that clip
I mean you know I think it was more
emotional for him than us only because
you know he's not done yet so yeah and
and I won't explain what that means but
the audience will soon understand what
I'm talking there's a lot of pauses and
us and there is probably just because he
doesn't want to give away any big
spoilers and there's just so much
information that they're not ready to
tell people yet but on a thematic level
if you want to talk about Captain
America going out think about it this
way he's a soldier
he's ready to give his life and willing
at every turn he has no problem dying
for his cause there's also that
foreshadowing scene from infinity war
where he says we don't trade lives as it
you know like he'd be willing to
sacrifice himself before he traded
someone else's life we'll talk more
about that when we get more Avengers and
game trailers maybe around the Superbowl
there could be an end game trailer maybe
a Captain Marvel promo then too but
we're getting a Captain Marvel trailer
next week so it just remains to be seen
how much footage they're gonna drop and
how much they're willing to spend on
those movies because a Super Bowl ad is
the most expensive one you could
possibly buy it's crazy
when brie Larson in this clip is talking
about Captain Marvel embodying strength
humility and compassion I think there's
a lot of the range of her character that
we haven't seen in the trailer so far
one of the
leading comments that I've seen on all
the Captain Marvel trailer videos that
I've done is that people feel like she's
emotionless she feels more like the Kree
soldier Captain Marvel just totally
hardcore dedicated to her cause not
thinking about a whole lot else but I
think she's coming off that way because
all the dialogue that we've seen from
her for the most part is from early in
the film before she starts to peel back
the onion layers of her memories and
learn that everybody's been lying to her
about her past there are a couple other
moments in this teaser video where you
do see her personality come through a
little bit there's more footage of her
trying to escape the scroll mind probe
device this is them just trying to
extract information from her remember
they're willing to do anything to win
the kree-skrull war so that's why they
have her upside down because she is one
of the kree's most powerful weapons and
probably knows most of their secrets
this year is probably a better example
of Captain Marvel's personality this is
Carol Danvers with Maria Bram Bowe aka
Photon remember Monica Rambo's mother
from the comics and I can't tell just
from this footage if it's meant to be a
flashback from before her accident with
a psyche magnetron or if it's later
after she's regained her memories but
since most of the footage we've seen of
her as an Air Force pilot with Maria
Rambo is from early in the movie I'm
guessing that that's when it's from like
there's some Air Force bar and it looks
like they're singing karaoke or
something like that but this shot of her
swapping the Carol Danvers name tag for
the brie Larson would on her flight suit
there is from her real-life Air Force
pilot training because she had to train
a little bit so that when they actually
do these scenes with her in the cockpit
especially early in the film they feel
authentic this shot of her in the Nine
Inch Nails t-shirt with Nick Fury in the
bar seems like it's still from pretty
early in the film when they're
explaining everything about each other
to each other where she's search for
memory more about her past Nick Fury
starts to explain what's happening with
shield and she tries to explain the
kree-skrull war to him and you know
scrolls can turn into anyone all the
mechanics of what it is that she's
trying to fight there's more footage of
Nick Fury with the alien cat it's called
goose in this movie in the comics it's
called Chewie I don't know why Star Wars
or Lucasfilm would prevent them from
using the Chewie name but you would
think with Marvel and Star Wars both
being Disney owned it would be a less of
a problem for them doing stuff like that
we're still not really sure where the
cat comes from within the context of the
movie because it's named goose after
goose in Top Gun in Carol Danvers isn't
supposed to remember her past when she's
with Starr forced so it wouldn't really
make sense for this version of Captain
Marvel who's been mindwiped
to know a bunch of earth references
spider-man style I'm sure she and Peter
Parker will have fun talking about
movies during the Avengers movies but
then they just have a really cool motion
poster and like the next big trailer
like I said is gonna be dropping Monday
night so of course I'll do a video for
that but there are a couple other promos
that they revealed to give you a little
bit more on each other's backstories and
they confirm Secret Invasion for the
scrolls
so this Nick Fury promo just reads in
the years following the Cold War Nick
Fury wrestles with his sense of purpose
within shield when Nick crosses paths
with Captain Marvel they become Earth's
only hope of stopping a Skrull invasion
then Talos has just reads perhaps the
most cunning spy in all the squirrel
Empire is a master of shape-shifting and
intergalactic
espionage an Integra leader in the
bitter Kree scroll war the fearsome
Talos will do whatever it takes to
protect his own so if it wasn't clear
they are going full-blown Secret
Invasion with the Captain Marvel movie
which is why I don't think they'll
completely repeat that plot after
avengers endgame we will continue to see
Scrolls pop up in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe it's just too useful of an
ability to have for fun story twists
like oh my god I thought this was my
friend that I've been talking to this
whole time when secretly it's a scroll
there'll always be fun moments like that
in future movies and we haven't even
gotten to the super scroll yet so it's
not like the Captain Marvel movie is
gonna be the last time you ever see them
even if she does put all these Scrolls
including Talos on ice let me know in
the comments though what are you most
excited for I know there's still lots of
questions about what's going on with the
movie with her powers how it's going to
fit into Avengers endgame obviously I
think we all have some post-credits
scene theories but no worries remember
trailer coming Monday night so that'll
be my next Captain Marvel video but
there will be some more Marvel tomorrow
to I'll be getting lots of specific
questions about Avengers endgame I'll
name a new giveaway winner when I post
new Marvel click here for that new Kevin
Feige
Avengers endgame x-men and Namor video
and click here for that other Captain
Marvel trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
you